[Musica]
buona sera io non sono forse il tipo di
linguista che vi che vi aspettate e non
vi dirò quello che un linguista
normalmente di solito dice non sono qui
per celebrare insieme a voi il funerale
l'ennesimo della lingua italiana
non sono qui per intonare il de
profundis del congiuntivo e del passato
remoto anche perché vi do una notizia
esclusiva il congiuntivo sta benissimo
non sono qui per dirvi signora mia dove
andrà a finire il nostro bell'italiano
calpestato vilipeso e insozzato dai
giovani no non sono qui per spiegarvi
quanto siano diventati ignoranti anzi
quando sono diventati ignoranti gli
altri perché gli ignoranti sono sempre
gli altri mai noi non sono qui per dare
conferme ai nostri pregiudizi e rispetto
al funzionamento della lingua insomma
non sono qui per vendere le tre merci
che non solo tra gli appassionati di
lingua hanno più mercato
nostalgia indignazione e paura
non sono qui per fare questo non sono
qui per neppure per fare cose necessarie
che io da insegnante faccio che tutti
gli altri tanti altri fanno e lo fanno
anche meglio di me cioè spiegare che
cosa è giusto e cosa è sbagliato stilare
cataloghi di cose da non dire di errori
da non fare
non sono qui per dare consigli di bonton
linguistico per illustrare sintomi
diagnosi e terapia di quella che viene
considerata è rappresentata con una
malattia e non sono un medico men che
meno un medico legale io sono qui per
celebrare il disordine linguistico e con
esso se non la bellezza quantomeno
l'ineluttabilità la democraticità
l'utilità e financo la razionalità
dell'errore la possibilità di sbagliare
non è infatti soltanto la principale
garanzia della nostra libertà e anche
e soprattutto il principale indicatore
della vitalità di un idioma
esiste forse nella nostra in qualunque
altra lingua
una cosa più intimamente grammatica
dell'errore no non esiste l'errore è la
quintessenza della grammatica perché non
è una semplice violazione di una regola
ma è una violazione basata su un'ipotesi
alternativa di funzionamento della
lingua
insomma è un infrazione della norma che
presuppone un altro di norma insomma
un'altra grammatica
eppure la tentazione di trenitalia le
regole di metterlo alla berlina di
sentirci migliori degli altri per il
solo fatto di aver avuto magari
un'educazione migliore è forte così
forte da farci dimenticare una serie di
una serie di elementi che il primo
elemento è questo e cioè che tutti gli
errori hanno un movente il cuore il
cuore scritto con la cura non so se se
se vi sarà capitato un'esperienza del
genere magari in casa in cucina c'è una
piastrella leggermente sollevate voi ci
andate ma regolarmente inciampare sopra
e voi lo sapete che c'è quella
piastrella leggermente sollevata
rispetto al piano di calpestamento da
cucina però nonostante questo ci finita
sempre per inciampare perché ci
inciampate per colpa vostra
certo ma magari anche per colpa del
piastrellista che a suo tempo ha
piazzato ha posato male la la piastrella
trasliamo questo discorso alla lingua di
chi è il vero re
di chi è la colpa dell'errore è colpa di
chi lo commette sì certo
alla lunga è colpa anche sua ma è anche
colpa della lingua se ci pensate
qua abbiamo un'immagine notate che le
power point dei linguisti
tendenzialmente sono un pochino più
brutti i linguisti sono più credibili
quanto peggiori sono i loro power point
poi si sono in grado di rendersi più
credibili qui abbiamo un'immagine del
del nostro ex premier e attuale
segretario del partito democratico
e stato lui a scrivere queste parole è
stato uno dei suoi collaboratori più più
sventati che ha scritto alla parola
scienziato la scritta senza lei o errore
vedremo tanti di noi
eppure eppure un errore che tutti tutti
quanti abbiamo abbiamo commesso per
descrivere scienza o coscienza senza lei
da piccoli e perché perché quella i non
si pronuncia è una assolutamente inutile
nel sistema della della nostra lingua e
di cui non abbiamo alcun bisogno la
grafia l'ortografia della lingua e
contro intuitiva e viola essa stessa la
regola che la lingua italiana si è data
ha codificato quindi essere sbagliata
certo è quella forma e scienziato
scritto senza lei ma essere sbagliate
anche la lingua
pensate al scrivere colazione con la
doppia z anziché con una z sola
oppure dire gli uovi non si che le uova
o mi par se anziché mi parve oppure
quelli che si dicono io stesso credo di
dirlo quando magari sono un po
disattendere a manca invece di a marca
per analogia con adipe avido arido asino
anima un alito acino a acido acino cioè
la maggior parte delle parole dire il 90
per cento delle parole che cominciano
con ha composte di tre sillabe in
italiano sono sono sdrucciole a marca è
l'unica eccezione insomma noi
commettiamo degli errori perché la
lingua stessa ci induce a commetterli
perché la lingua stessa
ogni tanto ti solleva la piastrella
etici fa inciampare gli errori di oggi
potrebbe non esserlo più domani non
voglio che i nostri destini si perdono
nell'infinito tu io naturalmente qui o
vi mostro un diciamo un riassunto una
sintesi di florilegi ben più ampi di
errori che voi potete trovare
facendo una qualunque ricerca online
in che senso l'errore di oggi potrebbero
potrebbe non esserlo più domani beh ne
vediamo qua un altro esempio non ho
nulla di personale naturalmente contro
contro il nostro ex premier e neppure
con contro il suo fido collaboratore
quale come si scrive quale si scrive
naturalmente senza senza l'apostrofo
naturalmente fino a un certo punto
naturalmente non è
l'avverbio giusto perché perché in
realtà
naturalmente ci vien fatto di scriverlo
con l'apostrofo quale per analogia con
la serie di domande di diciamo di
particelle interrogative seguite dal dal
verbo essere
dove con l'apostrofo cos'è come quando
eccetera
l'unica eccezione è quale poi si certo
qualcuno potrà ricordarmi lo sappiamo
che effettivamente quale una particella
che ha una sua vita autonoma la qualcosa
nel qual caso eccetera
però non c'è niente da fare per noi
quale fa parte di quella serie lì e io
stesso me ne rendo conto quando magari
sono un po sono lì che scrivo
sovrappensiero mi vien fatto di scrivere
quel quell'apostrofo non viene fatto di
scriverlo soltanto a me ma a una
maggioranza direi abbastanza ampia dei
nostri dei nostri concittadini se è vero
che se voi andate a googlare le forme
quale è scritto con l'apostrofo e quale
è scritto senza troverete risultati più
o meno equivalenti anzi man mano che
passa il tempo e grazie al fatto che poi
il google è un enorme frullatore che
tiene dentro tutto scoprirete che man
mano qual è scritto con l'apostrofo sta
prendendo sempre più piede
significa che corretto no in questo
momento non lo è probabilmente non lo
sarà ancora
ancora per i prossimi dieci quindici
venti anni verrà un giorno però questa è
una previsione che io faccio poi
eventualmente testate la fra 10 15 20
anni
verrà un giorno in cui probabilmente le
grammatiche noi stessi e le nostre
abitudini il nostro la nostra
sensibilità si dovranno arrendere e
dovranno appunto prendere atto che quale
è scritto con l'apostrofo è diventato
giusto come magari un po con l'accento
magari ma questo è già successo
piuttosto che piuttosto che script con
valore con valore disgiuntivo piuttosto
che con il significato di oppure che uno
degli orrori una quello che i linguisti
a cui i linguisti hanno dedicato persino
persino dei libri hanno intitolato dei
libri al piuttosto che senza che questo
sia stato sufficiente a cambiarne il
destino ea fare in modo che questa forma
deplorata vituperata sia scomparsa anzi
in realtà vive ed è sempre più più sana
forte e inarrestabile oppure settimana
prossima settimana scorsa senza senza
l'articolo è brutto noi tutti abbiamo il
diritto di considerare brutte certe
forme e di prendere nelle distanze io
trovo e renda dal mio punto di vista
personale settimana prossima settimana
scorsa senza senza l'articolo però però
il destino
la stella storia va in una certa
direzione e noi possiamo anche fare le
barricate ma il più delle volte non
riusciamo a fermare bene l'errore che
stai correggendo altra cosa che spesso
ci dimentichiamo potrebbe non essere il
più grave
noi in italia c'è ancora un pregiudizio
positivo nei confronti dell'ortografia
l'ortografia viene considerata la cosa
più bella della lingua
in effetti è bella l'ortografia o meglio
sono brutti gli errori ortografici se io
vedo un errore ortografico e come vedere
una persona in giro con una macchia di
sugo sulla camicia con un calzino
spaiato eppure l'ortografia
sì per carità è brutta ma
tendenzialmente non pregiudica la
comunicazione tra le persone
l'errore ortografico non pregiudica la
se io scrivo perché con l'accento acuto
con l'accento grave oppure scrivo
province senza o con la io pure
scienziato che uno senza live si capisce
che cosa voglio dire si capisce che cosa
voglio scrivere molto spesso invece gli
errori più più importanti sono degli
errori che sono anche più difficile a
classificare e molto più difficili da
correggere e quelli sì che danneggiare
la convocazione però l'ortografia no
l'ortografia è considerata come una
specie di di diciamo di cosa sacra nella
nella nostra lingua in tutte le lingue e
l'ortografia è un po come violare la
costituzione come commettere un peccato
mortale per carità è un peccato
ed è un peccato che va sanzionato
eccetera ma qui forse si danno si dà un
pochino più di importanza rispetto a
quella che che sono i suoi effettivi
meriti bene le lingue nascono e muoiono
con gli errori accidenti se se le lingue
non cambiassero se non si commettessero
errori questa è una sembra una banalità
ma non lo è
ne parleremo ancora latino anzi un'opera
mentre parleremo ancora il proto
indoeuropeo che è quella lingua mitica
da cui deriverebbero insomma tutte le
lingue neolatine come la nostra
qui c'è un documento che forse qualcuno
di voi conosce e un documento di un
drammatico drammatico del iv secolo dopo
cristo che si chiamava probo che aveva
stilato una serie di una lista di parole
come venivano diciamo venivano scritte e
come invece si sarebbero dovute scrivere
c'è l'ex non c'è l'ex lanciano un lancia
auris non morir la faccia se non faccia
eccetera eccetera bene noi vediamo in
questa serie di parole speculum non
speculum che nelle versioni censurate
noi vediamo già le tracce di un esito
che e poi l'esito della lingua italiana
lo speculum diventare allo specchio il
veto luz che poi era diventato bay cruz
è diventato il nostro vecchio eccetera
eccetera insomma probo aveva già
individuato una serie di errori e li li
segnalava eli eli censurava è né punto
né vagheggiava l'eliminazione salvo poi
doversi evidentemente a rendere anche
lui di fronte a un fenomeno che poi ha
portato come esito alla lingua italiana
alcune forme che consideriamo le rate
non lo sono caramelle non ne voglio più
alberto lupo e mina
no è una forma che si chiama
dislocazione a sinistra quella cosa per
cui io anticipo un elemento della
comunicazione poi lo riprendo poco dopo
con un pronome è la stessa cosa di dire
a me mi piace oppure il libro l'ho letto
quante volte ci siamo sentiti dire che
quelle cose lì non si fanno belle non si
fanno ma si fanno lo facciamo tutti lo
facciamo tutti quando parliamo
e anche quando scriviamo e se lo
facciamo perché in qualche modo stiamo
dicendo una cosa diversa rispetto a
semplicemente non voglio più caramelle
stiamo dicendo una cosa diversa e stiamo
aggiungendo anche un informazione e lo
stesso discorso che vale per la roma
inizio frase non si inizia una frase con
una congiunzione non si può iniziare una
frase come io comma eccetera questo non
so se lo riconoscete l'immagine di una
bella di notte detto anche gelsomino
notturno come incomincia il gelsomino
notturno e saprà nel primo turno aderito
una poesia incomincia e non è soltanto
licenza poetica pensate
pensate per esempio a una una frase di
questo di questo genere
marco un ragazzo timido e noioso oppure
marco è un ragazzo timido punto è noioso
significano la stessa cosa no non
significano la stessa cosa
nel secondo caso marco è un ragazzo più
noioso che timido nel primo caso più o
meno i due i due difetti sono
equivalenti al secondo caso invece la
noia pesa molto molto di più anche tu
commettere errori anche tu anche anche
voi anch'io anche noi siamo fantozzi e
filini
noi commettiamo continuamente errori
diciamo reboanti invece di roboanti
invece dire bonante diciamo decade
invece di decenni piuttosto che invece
di oppure marco ed andrea invece di
macro andrea e se non commettiamo errori
quantomeno commettiamo degli sbagli tipo
questo tipo quello di daniela santanchè
che scrive se riuscisse il giornale a
fare con h ciò che noi non siamo
riusciti in vent'anni
ora possiamo pensare tutto il male
possibile daniela santanchè io un po lo
penso
ma non credo che sia colpa sua credo che
sia colpa piuttosto del suo correttore a
volte gli errori gli sbagli non sono
colpa nostra
sono colpa anche della tecnologia che
noi abbiamo inventato per risparmiarseli
soprattutto ricordiamo questo ricordiamo
che l'errore e sistematico mentre lo
sbaglio è accidentale se l'errore
sistematico se qualcosa che appunto
rientra in una dinamica di una coazione
a ripetere e perché appunto
evidentemente è la lingua stessa a
facilitarlo e dunque per concludere
questo intervento
io quello che invito a fare e che se
proprio dobbiamo prendercela con
qualcuno se proprio dobbiamo criticare
gli errori bene facciamolo con le
persone che per il ruolo che occupano
per il lavoro che fanno hanno delle
responsabilità particolari nei confronti
della lingua penso a insegnanti penso ai
personaggi televisivi ai politici alle
persone che occupano posizioni chiave
nella nella cultura lasciamo invece
impacci bambini lasciamo in pace gli
stranieri lasciamo in pace tutti coloro
per cui il inaccessibilità la parola in
qualche modo costituisce un
inaccessibilità al mondo ecco accanirsi
contro di loro accanirsi con i loro
errori
è un atto dal mio punto di vista di
viltà ed è una cosa che io vi invito a
non fare vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]